the term goal is such a
important and difficult to explain
concept right because what you want is a
way is like um
i think only conscious beings can have
conscious goals
everything else is doing selection
and but selection does invent goals and
in a way that um
the way that biology reinterprets the
past in the present
is kind of help out you to understand
there was a goal in the past now right
it's kind of like goals only exist back
in time
so
first of all um
only conscious beings can have
conscious goals i'm not even going to
touch that one
why
well
go for it come on what what the line
between conscious goals and uh
non-conscious goals exactly right and
also maybe just on top of that you said
a touring test for gold directed
behavior what's what's what's it what's
the tour what what does the touring test
potentially look like so if you got two
objects we were thinking about this so
we were we actually got some funding to
work to get on two teams so
i'm trying to do in part of this is i'm
trying to do a bit of theory and sarah
is teaching me a bit of theory and
sarah's trying to design experiments and
i'm teaching experiments because i think
it's really good for us to have that to
say
um when would a
so that's good i like this this i'm sure
we use the dandenite essay
yeah and i can't explain why we wouldn't
want to call it a turing test after but
yeah yeah so dan della wrote this really
nice essay about um
herding cats and free will inflation
the title is so pretty it's the actual
title i think so yeah hurting cats and
free will inflation yeah something like
that i mean it's not maybe not and so no
i think that's right so if you've got a
let's imagine you've got two objects on
a hillside
okay and this happens to be snowy hill
and let's just say you see an object go
rolling down the hill
or you you you you and the rocker rolls
downhill at the start goes to the end
how do that objects had a goal now you
unveil the object and you'll see it's
actually a skier
and the skier starts the top and goes
down the bottom
great
then you look at the rock rock rolls
down the hill gets to the bottom how can
you tell the difference between the two
so and what dan says is like well this
it's clear the skier's in control
and the um because they're adjusting
trajectory so there's some updating
going on then the only way you can
really do that is you have put the skier
back to the top of the hill again they
tend to start roughly in the same space
and probably go
take all that that complex set of
trajectories and end up pretty much at
the same finish point right with plus or
minus v meters whereas if it was just a
random rock going down random trajectory
that wouldn't happen and so what sarah
and i were kind of doing when we were
writing this grant we were like we need
to somehow
instantiate the skier and the rock in an
experiment and then say okay when does
the object when it so
for an object to have a goal it has to
have an update it has to have some
sensing and some kind of you know
in-built actuation to respond to the
environment and
and then we just have to iterate on that
and maybe sarah you can then fill in the
turing test part well yeah i guess the
motivation for me was slightly different
so i get really frustrated about
conversations about consciousness as
most people do um you know a lot of
people are
which is not necessarily related to to
free will directly or to this goal
directed behavior but i think there's a
whole set of bundled and related topics
here
but i think for me i was you know
everybody's always interested in
explaining intrinsic experience and
quantifying intrinsic experience and
there's all sorts of problems with that
um because you can never actually be
another physical system so you can't
know what it's like to be another
physical system um so i always thought
there must be some way of getting at
this problem about
if an agent or an entity is conscious or
at least has internal representations
and those are real physical things that
there it must
have causal consequences
so the way i would ask the question of
consciousness is not you know what is it
like intrinsically but if if things have
intrinsic experience
is there any observable difference from
the outside about the the kind of
causation that that physical system
would enact in and for me the most
interesting thing that humans do is have
imagination so like we can imagine
rockets centuries before we build them
they become real physical things because
we imagine them and people might
disentangle that from conscious
experience but i think a lot of the sort
of imagination we do is actually a
conscious process so then this becomes a
question of if i were observing systems
and i said one had an internal
representation which is slightly
different than a conscious experience
obviously so i'm entangling some
concepts but it's a loose set of thought
experiments
then how and i and i set them up in a
physically equivalent situation
um would it be the case that
there would be
experimental observables associated with
it and that that became the idea of
trying to actually
measure for internal representation or
consciousness so turing basically didn't
want to do that you just wanted the
machine that could emulate and trick you
into having the behavior but never dealt
with the internal experience because
he didn't know how to do that and i
guess i was wondering is there a way to
set up the experiment where you could
actually test for that
for imagination the blood
to the that there was something internal
going on some kind of
inner world as people say but i i or you
could say
you know like it actually is an agent
it's making decisions it has an internal
representation and whether you say
that's experience or not is a different
thing but at least the the feature that
there's some abstraction it's doing
that's not obvious from looking at the
physical substrates do you think it's
possible to do that kind of thing one of
the compelling things about the turing
test
is that
you know defining intelligent defining
any complicated concept
as
um as a thing like observing it from the
surface and not caring about what's
going on deep inside because how do you
know
that's the point so the idea is exactly
that so
what we're trying to do the turing test
for goal directedness is literally
take some objects that clearly don't
have any internal representation grains
of sand blowing on the beach or
something right
and i know a crab wandering around on
the beach
and then generating an experiment where
we literally the experiment generates an
entity that literally has no internal
representation to sand be like a drop
these are oil droplets actually what
i've got in mind a robot that makes all
droplets but then what we want to try
and do is train the oil droplets to be
like crabs
give them an internal representation
give them the ability to integrate
information from the environment so they
understand they remember the past
are in the present
and can imagine a future
and a very limited way their kind of
game engine their limited simulation of
the world
allows them to then make a decision
they're objects across time
you